sinha dopes a web series that has what
four or five episodes right now for
episode he's the one okay how did you
get involved in the project Brian drolet
he's the reason I did the show he's a
very funny talented writer and comedic
actor you know you got to start on the
hillside my perception and people
wouldn't think somebody from the hills
would have a brain or be a real talent
but he's really talented very
hardworking guy and he asked me if I
would play his co lead in the show and I
wanted to work with him so instantly I
was very intrigued and pretty much said
yes I said I read the scripts and just
make sure it vibe is what I like and I
read them in here oh very funny script
but he also said that he was open to you
know my input on scripts when he said
that I'm actually not because I'd been
really wanting to write something again
I hadn't written my own thing in love
her a long time and to collaborate with
Brian we rewrote all the scripts
together and we came out with what I
think it's a very unique funny pretty
out of the box comedy show it's a sitcom
for YouTube it's old-school over-the-top
kind of screwball comedy you'll see a
lot of that you see this uber subtle
sometimes bordering on boring comedies
and this one is just nuts its out of its
mind Brian I try to ground it a little
bit in our performances you know but and
to allow some of the rest of the
ensemble cast to go crazy but it's just
a funny weird world we created and it's
so odd that so many weird things happen
we have a super villain and we have you
know infestations of crazy animals and
we have people having sex everywhere we
have just like drop me web we have
popping smoked everywhere it's just it's
a weird Senna dope is a weird fun world
and it's a very good use I think of of
your 15 minutes x 4 episodes the people
if people will watch and like it we got
to make a season 2 so everybody wins
we'll see you people watching it and
then us making it again not people who
didn't see it those people lose or never
saw this interview and then those people
are to feel bad for those people right
but they should feel inspired if they're
staying at holiday and they should
you